[Música]
[Aplausos]
o
[Música]
quantos de vocês aqui se sentem
completamente seguros de uma saúde
estável de uma vida equilibrada eu nunca
vou ter um câncer
eu nunca vou ter uma diabetes sei lá
qualquer coisa e vocês podem matar ramón
quem estava streaming também aí ninguém
bom se alguém aqui por algum acaso é na
sua cabeça disse que sim eu estou
completamente seguro
ao final desses meus minutos vocês vão
entender que eu também acreditava que eu
estava sempre senti seguro da minha
saúde
mas como nem tudo são flores
eu vou dizer pra vocês que não foi bem
assim
primeiro eu quero me apresentar um pouco
eu quero te dizer que eu sou a completa
desconstrução do que a sociedade julga
como alguém assim do perfil digamos
ideal
primeiro eu sou menina estuda engenharia
já é bem louco né porque engenharia é um
curso para homens
eu sou uma moça da pele bem branquinha
mas do cabelo extremamente crespo louco
isso porque as pessoas ainda acreditam
que cabelo escolhe cor de pele não é
mesmo
e por último eu sou heterossexual que
significa que eu gosto de meninos e sou
soropositiva
sim eu tenho hiv e louco isso não é hiv
não era coisa de gay mas eu vou contar
pra vocês como foi que tudo isso começou
eu lembro que eu era muito novinha e à
minha família é chegou é porque eles
ficaram com os burburinhos ae flano de
tal é a idéia é tica eu lembro que era
uma prima minha prima bem distante e
futuro muitos meses a família fazendo
esse burburinho de que ela era a ideia
de que a idéia de que tudo mais
até que lá na minha no ensino
fundamental mais ou menos eu lembro que
na minha escola teve uma campanha dsts
bem grande né
e aí eles começaram a distribuir
cartilhas é com algumas doenças algumas
infecções sexualmente transmissíveis e
eu me lembro claramente
nesta campanha é a escola estava
distribuindo preservativos mas imagine
só uma criança de 10 e 11 anos levando
isso para casa
quem era o corajoso ninguém então a
gente via que ele na escola e voltava
pra casa ninguém tinha visto nada e esse
foi o meu único contato com as infecções
sexualmente transmissíveis
até que aos meus 23 anos de idade
hoje completa exatos 11 meses
eu não estava me sentindo muito legal e
eu falei
a médica me disse assim eu acho que você
precisa realizar algumas alguns desafios
uma bateria beleza aí foi que eu
realizei o exame o kit de st
batata uma semana depois estava
descobrindo uma nova soro positivo no
mundo e foi muito louco porque todo
mundo se questionava por que a banda
está com isso que louco é logo a banda
uma menina de tão poucos parceiros
sexuais e já estava com uma coisa muito
louca desta com aids ou o câncer o que e
eu me perguntava sempre nossa porque
porque que isso aconteceu justamente
comigo e eu confesso que a minha fase de
luto e aceitação ela foi muito pequena
fase do luto ea fase de aceitação ela
veio muito rápida e tudo tudo foi uma
nova descoberta foi que eu nasci de novo
e tive que reaprender a aprender nessa
minha nova jornada de vida eu aprendi
que o hiv e aids são coisas diferentes
permita-me aids são as doenças
oportunistas que acometem o indivíduo
quando a imunidade dele está muito
baixinha por conta do que o vírus faz no
nosso corpo então se eu não me trato se
eu não tomava medicação eu posso
desenvolver ou não as doenças
oportunistas legal nisso eu também fui
descobrir que hoje eu posso ser mamãe
geralmente posso ter uma relação sexual
natural engravidar
bom as relações sexuais são naturais e
aí descobri também que se eu atingir um
estágio do meu tratamento onde nós somos
considerados indetectáveis
eu já não transmito mais o vírus hiv de
forma sexuais certo
então se eu tenho a minha medicação faço
o meu acompanhamento vou no meu médico a
minha carga viral vai reduzindo até um
dia que eu posso me relacionar
sexualmente com um parceiro e aí ele não
vai é ser infectado pelo vírus combinado
então estava tudo certo na minha vida
falei estou completamente segura mas
tinha uma coisa uma coisinha que ainda
me deixava assim angustiado
eu pensava assim é nossa e agora quando
eu vou me relacionar com uma nova pessoa
e aí eu vou ter que contar para essa
pessoa que eu tenho hiv e aí é que eu tô
apaixonada e tudo mais a pessoa não quer
mais saber de você
pensei vou quebrar minha cara né mas eu
não queria quebrar minha cara e para
todas as pessoas que eu contava que
tinha hiv
o conselho era o mesmo pelo amor de deus
não conta isso pra ninguém fica só pra
você
o preconceito é muito grande então não
conta pra ninguém mas aquilo sabe eu
senti que aquilo de não poder contar
tava mesmo pagando por dentro ea então
com meu medo de não encontrar alguém que
aceitasse tive uma grande ideia mas foi
uma ideia grande e legal só pra mim para
minha família e para os meus amigos foi
uma loucura total
pensei vou gravar um vídeo porque eu já
tinha um canal no youtube que eu gravar
algumas coisinhas nada a ver corrigida
vou gravar um vídeo e eu vou colocar no
youtube e aí todas as pessoas vão saber
que eu tenho hiv
e aí o dia que
pareceu um novo pretendente eu vou ter
que explicar que eu tenho hiv não vou
correr o risco foi batata em duas
semanas 50 mil pessoas já sabiam que eu
tinha hiv
e aí vocês acham que apareceram pedidos
bom apareceram muitos pedidos mas aí é
que vem a parte um pouco séria dessa
palestra nenhum pedido de namoro
obviamente mas muitos muitos pedidos de
socorro
entre as histórias que eu comecei a
escutar uma delas uma moça tinha acabado
de descobrir a gravidez e eu não sei se
vocês sabem mas no pré-natal assuma mais
linhas precisam realizar seus exames nas
suas testagens e nessa e com dois meses
de gravidez ela descobriu o sensor
positiva e ela disse que naquele dia ela
queria estava determinada a se jogar de
um prédio do sétimo andar
quem ela teve um insight falou vou
assistir a um vídeo alguma coisa tem que
mudar essa idéia e ela sentou em frente
a um computador e assistir um vídeo meu
e nesse vídeo que gravei eu tava me
maquiando coisa que eu não sei fazer
toda louca falando que eu tinha pegado
aí vem me maquiando e o delineado todo
louco e ela disse que vendo aquele vídeo
ela ficou impressionada como pode uma
pessoa que tem hiv está vivendo
normalmente e aí ela desistiu da idéia
dela de suicídio e hoje eu acreditar que
ela está pertinho de ganhar o bebê dela
essas pessoas são inúmeras
me procuram todos os dias pra contar
suas histórias pra contar suas
experiências para contar o medo que elas
têm de falar sobre isso para outras
pessoas e isso tudo sabe
veio uma uma grande descoberta e também
um novo mais um novo reaprendizado eu
entendi
nessa minha caminhada que é daí ver não
é mais um problema de saúde mas sim um
problema social
e me assustou muito depois que eu
comecei a gravar vídeos para internet
sobre hiv
descobri que a maioria das pessoas que
morrem em decorrência da aids em países
onde o tratamento é gratuito e eficaz é
justamente por não aderirem ao
tratamento por medo medo de buscar em
seus remédios medo de assumir em para
suas famílias que são soropositivas medo
de serem descobertas medo de fazer as
sustenta testagens e aquilo me
impressionou muito
como é que pode as pessoas morrerem por
causa do preconceito né
daí eu fui entender porque aquela
pergunta que eu me fazia logo no início
precisava de uma resposta agora depois
de me tornar uma ativista em defesa das
pessoas portadoras do hiv e aids
eu entendi que eu precisava ser
infectada para que eu aprendesse sobre
isso e servisse como voz pra mais de 34
milhões de pessoas no mundo que são
portadoras do vírus
eu precisava com a minha vida e com a
minha saúde
falar em nome dessas pessoas levar tapas
na cara por essas pessoas esporro a
minha vida por essas pessoas para
mostrar aqui vai ver já deixou de ser um
problema de saúde
para mostrar que não é mais como o tempo
de cazuza de renato que muitos de vocês
já devem conhecer as histórias
hoje 40 anos depois é tudo muito
diferente mas mais que isso eu quero
dizer que o hiv é uma realidade que um
dia estava muito distante de mim e hoje
ele mora no meu corpo mas quer saber que
isso não era só comigo que é um exemplo
quantos aqui já fizeram tatuagem tem
tatuagem uma galera em vou entrar para
esse time está criando coragem
quantos aqui bom não vou tentar isso
porque pode ser um pouco atrevido demais
pra vocês mas talvez muitos aqui nesse
auditório já tenham precisado de uma
transfusão de sangue ou mesmo já tenham
se relacionado sem preservativo eu digo
de relações com penetração e relações
orais beleza mas vamos um pouco mais a
fundo talvez você não se encaixe e
nenhuma desses quesitos aí todos aqui
nasceram de uma barriga certo
bom gente eu quero acreditar que todos
vieram de uma barriga normalzinho comum
você também já correu o risco de ser
infectado pelo vírus
mesmo porque a transmissão ocorre de mãe
para o bebê
se não existe um tratamento adequado
viu que a realidade pode não ser a
realidade de vida de vocês mas é uma
coisa à qual você também já se
dispuseram dia e talvez nem soubessem
disso então a minha luta hoje é
justamente para mostrar que nós
portadores de hiv e nós somos pessoas
normais
o trabalho eo estudo eu me relaciono eu
tô aqui no tek niterói ea minha vida é
completamente normal como a de vocês
os amigos me perguntam o que eu sinto de
efeitos colaterais
eu vivo normal minha vida é
completamente normal mas tem uma coisa
que ainda me incomoda o fato de grande
parte do público com quem eu me encontro
com quem eu vejo nas palestras com quem
eu me deparo no canal do youtube não
terem coragem de fazer os seus exames de
hiv
então a minha luta justamente para
conscientizar essas pessoas vocês a
conhecerem a fazerem as suas testagens a
conhecerem a sua sorologia porque quanto
antes a gente descobre melhor e mais
eficaz é o nosso tratamento então nós
soropositivos não queremos disse
jamais não queremos tratamentos
especiais
nós só queremos ser aceitos em uma
sociedade mais amorosa mais respeitosos
porque aliás fomos como disse normais
se você me encontrar por aí por favor me
deu um abraço porque tudo que nós
precisamos é de mais amor e respeito
[Aplausos]
[Música]